there is controversy this morning over
house speaker nancy pelosi's trip to
asia she visited malaysia overnight and
there are reports she may also go to
taiwan that could anger china which
considers the sovereign island nation to
be part of its territory nancy cordes is
at the white house nancy good morning
what do we know
what we know nate is that the plane that
had been carrying speaker pelosi's
delegation took off from kuala lumpur in
malaysia a couple of hours ago but we
don't know whether the speaker is on
that plane we don't know where it's
headed and she still hasn't confirmed
that she does indeed intend to visit
taiwan but chinese officials once again
this morning are warning her not to go a
spokeswoman there saying quote the u.s
side will bear the responsibility and
pay the price for undermining china's
sovereign security interests there are
also reports from the region that
chinese war planes are behaving
provocatively this morning flying right
along the median line in the center of
the taiwan strait
white house officials are urging china
not to overreact here's secretary of
state anthony blinken
if the speaker does decide to visit
and china tries to
create some kind of crisis or otherwise
escalate tensions
that would be entirely
on beijing
congressional delegations to taiwan are
not unusual there have been several
others just this year to show support
for that island democracy but it is very
rare for very high-ranking u.s officials
to visit taiwan given the ambiguity over
china's claim to the island and if
speaker pelosi does indeed visit taiwan
she'll be the first u.s house speaker to
do so in 25 years vlad i'm told we'll
know more about her travel plans by
mid-morning
all right all eyes to the east nancy
thank you as always we appreciate it